[Music]
this is your tech news briefing for
thursday july 28th i'm zoe thomas for
the wall street journal
getting capital for an early stage
startup is crucial if an idea is going
to grow into a full-blown business and
venture capital has typically been there
ready to invest
but there are signs of a pullback in the
second quarter of this year vcs invested
around 16 billion dollars in u.s early
stage deals typically called series a
and series b rounds that's according to
data from pitch book
it's a 22
drop from the same time a year earlier
and the biggest quarterly year-over-year
decline in early stage funding since
2010 with the exception of the second
quarter of 2020 during the pandemic
lockdowns
so why is this pullback so drastic and
what will it mean for the development of
young startups
joining us to discuss this is our
reporter berber gin
hi berber thanks for being here hi zoe
good to be here so for a long time we've
been hearing about how easy it is to get
startup funding why are we seeing this
pullback now you know the biggest reason
is the sell-off in technology stocks in
the public market
so startup investors usually look at
those companies as a way to price the
rounds that they invest in for private
companies and so
the broader market sell-off combined
with some concerns over
inflation and a potential recession is
making
venture capitalists a lot more
conservative about investing in startups
you know early startup funding has
typically not been as affected by these
stock market dips why are we seeing you
know those companies being impacted in a
way we traditionally see with kind of
larger later stage startups yeah that's
a great question it was interesting i
mean at the beginning of the year when a
lot of investors were pulling back from
investing in
larger companies a lot of early stage
venture capitalists were pretty
confident that
that part of the market would be
insulated just because the companies are
so young and they're so far away from
going public but i think the pullback in
a lot of the large money managers that
were
pumping up the valuations for startups
last year the fact that they're no
longer in the market
means that a lot of these earlier
companies can't really raise follow-on
rounds of funding
and
venture capitals that are backing these
younger companies relied on those big
grounds and those large markups to
generate a paper return on their funds
and so now i think early stage vcs are
understandably nervous about backing
companies that might not be able to
generate
added funding in future financing rounds
and so i think the broader slowdown in
the
market for more mature startups is sort
of
seeping into the early stage
investing environment and i think
generally the sort of nervousness around
you know how severe the cooldown in the
vc market will be is is just causing
investors across the spectrum to become
very careful
in selecting startups to back
so how are early stage startups handling
this
some some startups are in a tough
position because they raised a lot of
money at high prices last year before
they really developed
products that were proven to have
traction in the market and be popular
with users so a lot of those companies i
mean they're running out of cash they
don't have stable revenue streams and
what's happening is that they're turning
to their existing investors and asking
for these
emergency funding rounds essentially
trying to get you know a few million
more dollars on their balance sheet at
the same price as their previous round
to try and ride out you know the sort of
tougher fundraising environment but it
definitely puts even these younger
companies in a tough spot because
it'll be hard for them to raise cash at
higher prices than what they raised last
year
given how much more discerning investors
are being with
you know evaluating financial metrics
and making sure startups hit revenue
numbers and have a strong path to
profitability
those things weren't really in the
picture as much last year for buzzy
companies
does that mean the startups are really
having to kind of change their strategy
you know how they run their business
entirely
now more than ever startups are
facing the pressure to show that they
can grow in a sustainable way i think
last year because companies were
receiving so much funding
they were sort of blowing through cash
they were hiring a lot they were
spending a lot of marketing they're
spending a lot on
recruiting now
what investors are expecting for
companies is to show that
they can grow but can grow in a
profitable way and show that if the
times get tough they can easily find a
way to survive without burning through
cash so just using the buzziest terms
isn't gonna bring in the money it used
to
you know you've spoken with investors
about this environment how do they say
it compares to previous slowdowns
this one is really severe i mean
you know obviously the venture market is
quite cyclical you know there are bull
markets and then there are market
corrections but a lot of the vc's i've
spoken with and you know they'll even
say this publicly like this is probably
the slowest environment they've seen and
the toughest fundraising environment
they've seen in the last 10 to 15 years
and so i think most venture capitalists
are bracing for a tighter market over
the next couple of years even
so i think it's definitely a pretty rude
awakening for
silicon valley especially given the
backdrop of the pandemic and low
interest rates and how that sort of
fueled
what was probably the craziest bubble
for the startup market in recent history
okay so the slowest and possibly the
toughest market for raising money in but
according to pitchbook vcs had a record
in raising funds last year and they're
on track to do the same this year so
what's gonna happen with all that money
i mean that is an open question
as to how that capital will be deployed
in the future
one thing that could happen is
these funds could start doing deals that
involve some debt elements or
you know more investor protections for
equity that they buy
you see that a lot in down cycles and
and that could be a way in which some of
the capital is invested
so the time of easy money seems to be
over for startups i guess right sadly
for the startups and i guess maybe the
investors as well
all right that's our reporter berber gin
thanks so much for joining us berber
thanks so i appreciate it
and that's it for today's tech news
briefing if you want more tech stories
check out our website wsj.com
and if you like our show please rate and
review it you can do that wherever you
get your podcasts
i'm zoe thomas for the wall street
journal
thanks for listening
[Music]
you